The Ouroboros Cycle.
One of the biggest, most legendary series
of entries in the history of the SCP Foundation.
We’ve covered the events of this SCP-001
epic in six videos - which, we definitely
recommend you watch before this one to avoid
your brain exploding from the sheer scope
of it all.
Because that’s the thing about the Ouroboros
Cycle - it’s a story so big, sprawling,
and dense that it can feel almost like an
anomaly itself.
Whether you’re immersed in the possible
origin of the Broken God, the sentient black
hole that can destroy whole universes, or
Calvin Lucien’s quest to assassinate the
O5 Council, it can sometimes be difficult
to see the forest of the trees.
But worry not, because that’s exactly why
we’re here today.
We’re going to step back and look at this
anomalous odyssey as a whole, and ask the
big question: Why is it all here together?
What makes these four different storylines
- The Children, The Broken God, Atonement,
and The Way It Ends - one big cycle?
As with anything involving the SCP Foundation,
there’s always going to be an element of
personal interpretation, but now that we’ve
gone through the whole cycle, we think it’s
worth adding our two cents to the proceedings.
So, let’s start broad.
A question you’ve probably been wondering
is, what do the words “Ouroboros Cycle”
actually mean?
And what is their significance to the four
stories within?
While the spelling can differ, Ouroboros refers
to the ancient symbol of a snake or dragon
eating its own tail, forming a circle - a
direct connection to the concept of “cycles.”
The Ouroboros symbol has existed in a huge
number of cultures, from the Ancient Egyptians
to the Ancient Greeks to modern Gnostic traditions.
It’s often used in alchemy or other magical
practices, and has a variety of meanings such
as eternal life, the endless cycle of death
and rebirth, and the cycle of renewal.
Anyone familiar with the tales within the
Ouroboros Cycle is probably already noticing
some similarities.
Cycles are a common theme in all of these
works.
People endlessly repeat mistakes, threats
thought to be contained or destroyed return,
and oftentimes, those who go out on a quest
to destroy something end up becoming what
they wished to destroy in the first place.
In a cycle, there is no true end and no true
beginning.
Everything repeats endlessly.
But let’s start at the closest thing to
a beginning we have: The Children.
In this tale, the Foundation faces off against
a terrifying, reality-warping group of interest
known as the Kingdom of Abaddon.
This nasty group which came from the Sahara
desert could seemingly take anything the Foundation
threw at them, and were able to straight-up
vaporize anyone who got too close.
If the Kingdom was able to amass enough power,
it could spell the end of the Foundation,
and even the subjugation of the human race.
Enter O5-1, a recurring character in the Ouroboros
Cycle.
This outside the box thinker put all his chips
on the Twins of God Project, designated SCP-001,
like many anomalies before and after it.
This project would infuse a human being with
godlike powers, but it was a power so great
that it seemed to kill anyone who attempted
to accept it.
Needless to say, this was a major bummer for
O5-1, but through relentless human experimentation
- even sacrificing the population of entire
towns to the project - he eventually came
up with a solution.
A horrifying solution, but a solution nonetheless.
He found that a group of nine children, with
ages varying from four to eleven, could act
as a human conduit for 001’s power - and
as a result, it could be the weapon capable
of turning the tide against the Kingdom of
Abaddon.
During the testing phase, though, it seemed
like O5-1 went a little mad with power.
He vaporized an entire Church of the Broken
God place of worship, and used the power of
The Children to wipe a few others off the
map at his own discretion.
His abuses of power got so flagrant that The
Administrator himself was called in to get
a handle on the situation.
And, surprise surprise, O5-1 disintegrated
him too, before disappearing himself shortly
afterwards.
In the end, The Children were deemed too dangerous
to be practical, both because of their anomalous
powers and from the level of ambient radiation
they put out.
All nine were locked in radiation-proof boxes
and buried in the desert, though they each
show signs of life to this day.
While this may seem disconnected from the
rest of the series, it actually establishes
some of the most important recurring themes
and ideas of the Cycle as a whole.
Namely, the Foundation messing with reality
and performing horrific acts to achieve their
goals, the corruption of the O5 Council, and
the fact that these grand attempts to change
or save the world often blow up in everyone’s
faces, sometimes literally.
We also have the introduction and apparent
death of the mysterious Administrator, but
trust us, all is not what it seems with this
one.
The ripple effect beginning here will affect
everything going forward.
Next, The Broken God.
This tells the chaotic story of a magical
clockwork box which is worshipped by the Church
of the Broken God as a conduit to their deity,
and eventually becomes an all-devouring, mechanical
kaiju.
The beast - soon dubbed SCP-001 - devoured
and consumed all the metal around it, slowly
becoming larger and more destructive.
If the Foundation didn’t take it out before
it reached critical mass, they’d be going
toe to toe with a bonafide God - a fight they
really weren’t sure they could win.
Thankfully, and with a little anomalous help
from SCP-2399, the Foundation was able to
destroy the anomaly.
They removed its clockwork heart from the
wreckage and contained the anomalous scrap
that once comprised its destructive body.
However, the Foundation soon realized that
you just can’t keep a good God down.
The clockwork heart eventually evaded Foundation
containment while being shipped to a secondary
location, and instead ended up in a small
town.
Here, it began to influence the minds of the
residents into more subservient Broken God
cultists, intent on building him back up to
his former glory.
It’d be easy to discount The Broken God
as an outlier, seeing as the Foundation came
out looking much better here than they do
in any of the other Ouroboros tales.
But when you look carefully, its place in
the overall Cycle is clear.
The entry ends the way it begins, with the
heart of the Broken God influencing humans
to carry out its bidding.
The Foundation had to intervene in between
these two instances, but in the end, there
was no net loss to the Broken God itself.
In a sense, the Foundation is doomed to encounter
the same problems again and again, continually
defending the world from the same anomalous
threats.
And the Foundation needs to succeed every
time to maintain peace and normality.
A major anomalous threat only needs to succeed
once to drag everything into disarray.
In many ways, that is the curse of the SCP
Foundation.
Speaking of major anomalous threats, now it’s
time for part three of the Ouroboros Cycle:
Atonement.
Once again, we start off with the Foundation
meddling with cosmic-scale powers with the
creation of the Area-11 Pietrykau-Fontaine
Spatial Stabilization Array.
Try saying that three times fast!
This was a machine so powerful it was capable
of creating a singularity, though what it
actually ended up doing was turning Dr. Calvin
Desmet into an abomination.
More specifically, into a kind of immensely
powerful humanoid black hole, whose powers
were only restrained by the very machine that
created him.
Think of him as a kind of malicious Doctor
Manhattan from Watchmen.
This new entity, dubbed SCP-001, presented
a grim prophecy and an ominous offer.
He told the O5 Council that anomalies were
leaking into their universe from other realities,
and soon, the anomalous threat would destroy
them all.
His offer was to, upon his release, wipe out
the rest of the multiverse entirely, leaving
only our reality, free from anomalous threats.
Unsurprisingly, it was O5-1 that was most
interested in this offer - so much so that
he held a vote, and murdered everyone who
voted against the decision to release SCP-001.
Having built his consensus among the survivors
on the council, O5-1 let SCP-001 out.
Unsurprisingly, this turned out to be a terrible
decision, as one of his first acts upon being
freed was to kill the members of the O5 Council
that had just voted to release 001, saying
that they themselves were anomalous and needed
to be purged to atone for their past sins.
The only survivor was the member of the Council
who abstained from the vote, who was able
to recontain SCP-001 inside the Pietrykau-Fontaine
Array...for now.
Once again, the thematic connections to the
rest of the Ouroboros Cycle is clear.
We have a world-ending anomaly held off, but
only temporarily, buying time before the cycle
inevitably continues.
We have the Foundation abusing its power,
and signing off on the death of countless
people in other dimensions.
And of course, the O5 Council stepped out
of their bounds and actively warped reality,
just like they had with The Children before.
Their chickens truly come home to roost though
in the final part of the cycle.
Appropriately named The Way It Ends, this
piece chronicles the story of Calvin Lucien
and the Killsquad, an elite group of four
Chaos Insurgency soldiers with one goal: Assassinating
the entire O5 Council, thirteen of the most
powerful people in the world.
Why?
Because they’ve been messing with reality
itself time and time again, and it’s getting
to the point that their selfish meddling could
finally destroy everything.
And given that we’ve already seen it happen
with The Children and the entity that Dr.
Calvin Desmet became, it’s hard to disagree
with them.
What follows is one of the longest and most
complicated tales in all of the Foundation,
as the Killsquad systematically encounters
and kills each insane, anomalous member of
the O5 Council.
In order to do this, they need to make deals
with Death itself, fight giant serpents, cross
dimensions, deal with SCP-610 and SCP-682
containment breaches, and go toe to toe with
Samsara, arguably the Foundation’s deadliest
Mobile Task Force.
A number of other insane things happen along
the way, like O5-1 murdering the Gate Guardian
with a Scranton Reality Anchor, and the Black
Queen - the most prominent member of the Serpent’s
Hand - helping our heroes defeat more Overseers.
In the end, Calvin Lucien, despite losing
almost everything, reigns victorious in the
final battle.
Using The Spear of the Non-Believer, a weapon
so powerful it can kill Gods, Calvin managed
to finally kill the top member of the Overseers,
O5-1.
With the O5 Council destroyed, Calvin set
about completing his final task: Destroying
the entire SCP Foundation.
But that didn’t happen.
Instead, he was contacted by a mysterious
and immensely powerful being known as The
Administrator, who gave him some frightening
news: He’d just been hired by the SCP Foundation
to be their new O5-1.
This was where our last video on the Ouroboros
series left us.
What happens next, you may ask?
How does Calvin respond to this offer he seemingly
can’t refuse?
In this case, it seems that the Administrator,
a being so completely tied to the nature of
the Foundation itself, is SCP-001.
And while it seemed that the Overseers were
mad with power, they were actually always
there to keep the Administrator in check.
Aaron Siegler, the O5-1 that Calvin had just
killed, was doing the exact same thing Calvin
was doing when he became O5-1: Trying to destroy
the Foundation.
But the Foundation and the Administrator cannot
be beaten, they can only be joined.
And that’s exactly what Calvin did, becoming
the new O5-1, turning his back on the Chaos
Insurgency, and rebuilding the rest of the
council and the Foundation in his own image.
Insurgency members who were once his allies
vowed revenge for this betrayal, perhaps suggesting
that history would go on to repeat itself
once more in future.
Because, at the end of the day, that’s what
the Ouroboros Cycle really is - the recurring
threat and the changing of the guards that
accompanies it.
There will always be a Foundation, there will
always be an Administrator, there will always
be an O5 Council.
Nothing starts, nothing ends, all that ever
changes are the names and faces involved - whether
it’s Calvin Lucien or Aaron Siegler, the
wheel keeps turning, the snake devours its
own tail.
The Ouroboros Cycle is, and forever will be,
eternal.
Now go check out our full, piece by piece
breakdown on the Ouroboros cycle starting
with SCP-001 The Children, and then check
out “SCP-5000 Why?
- The Full Story Compilation”, just in case
we haven’t blown your mind enough for one
day!